die grundakten die unversehrtheit und
unverrückbar kite von grenzen sowie die
souveränität eines jeden landes gilt es
zu achten das ist die basis auf diesem
prinzip fußen weite teile unserer
nachkriegsordnung
mit der anerkennung der beiden provinzen
im osten der ukraine hat russland gegen
diese grundprinzipien verstoßen die lage
heute ist damit eine grundlegend andere
nun ist es an der internationalen
gemeinschaft auf diese einseitigen und
verständlichen und ungerechtfertigten
handlungen des russischen präsidenten zu
reagieren eng abgestimmt gut koordiniert
und zielgerichtet
damit wir ein klares signal an moskau
senden dass solche handlungen nicht ohne
konsequenz bleiben werden
international stimmen wir uns eng ab im
un-sicherheitsrat haben wir und andere
staaten gestern nacht bereits deutlich
gemacht dass russland keinerlei rückhalt
hat in der welt für sein vorgehen
der ukrainische präsident zealand ski
verdient unseren höchsten respekt dafür
dass sich sein land nicht provozieren
lässt von russland denn genau darauf
wartet der russische präsident um ein
vorwand zu haben
möglicherweise die gesamte ukraine zu
besetzen
innerhalb der europäischen union haben
wir ein erstes z an sanktionen
miteinander besprochen und werden sie
noch im laufe des tages gemeinsam
beschließen
sprach davon die lage ist heute eine
grundlegend andere
und deshalb
müssen wir angesichts der jüngsten
entwicklung diese lage auch neu bewerten
übrigens auch im hinblick auf nach dem 2
ich habe das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium heute
gebeten den bestehenden bericht zur
analyse der versorgungssicherheit bei
der bundesnetzagentur zurückzuziehen es
ging zwar technisch ist aber der nötige
verwaltungsrechtliche schippt damit
jetzt keine zertifizierung der pipeline
erfolgen kann und ohne diese
zertifizierung kann holz den zwei gar
nicht in betrieb gehen die zuständige
abteilung des
bundeswirtschaftsministerium wird eine
neue bewertung der sicherheit unserer
versorgung und der berücksichtigung
dessen vornehmen was sich in den
vergangenen tagen verändert hat in
dieser phase ist es jetzt richtig neben
ersten sanktionen eine weitere
eskalation und damit eine katastrophe zu
verhindern
darauf zielen alle unsere diplomatischen
anstrengungen es sind sehr schwere tage
und stunden für europa ich glaube 80
jahre nach dem ende des zweiten
weltkrieges brot ein krieg im osten
europas es ist unsere aufgabe eine
solche katastrophe abzuwenden und ich
appelliere erneut in russland dabei zu
helfen vielen dank
[Musik]
schönen dank für ihre frage und ich will
gerne darauf antworten für uns ist es
ganz ganz wichtig dass wir gemeinsam
handeln als europäische union und auch
in enger abstimmung mit den vereinigten
staaten von amerika das ist das was wir
gerade vorbereitet haben und worüber
jetzt die diskussion im gange sind es
geht um entschiedene
maßnahmen die wir jetzt ergreifen
bezogen auf die aktion die jetzt
stattgefunden hat nämlich die
anerkennung der beiden
gebietskörperschaften als eigene
republiken was nicht hingenommen werden
kann und selbstverständlich haben wir in
der langen zeit in der wir diese
situation vorbereitet haben noch weitere
sanktionen die wir ergreifen können
falls es zu weiteren maßnahmen kommt
aber jetzt geht es erstmal darum etwas
ganz konkretes zu machen das sich auf
die situation die jetzt eingetreten es
bezieht und auch ähnliche maßnahmen zu
ergreifen die abgestimmt sind zwischen
den usa und der europäischen union und
das wird passieren
vielen dank herr bundeskanzler sie haben
ja gerade gesagt dass das
zertifizierungsverfahren für zwei
ausgesetzt wird mich würde interessieren
unter welchen bedingungen könnte es
wieder eingesetzt werden welche
bedingungen musste russland erfüllen ich
würde auch interessieren ob das nein
zu waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
angesichts der neuen situation wieder in
frage gestellt wird oder ob sie dabei
bleiben
und mich würde interessieren dass
münster abkommen ist ja quasi mit dem
heutigen tag
hinfällig bedeutet das dass auch das
normandie format tot ist oder
versuchen und damit auch die deutschen
vermittlerrolle oder versuchen sie da
auch gespräche wieder in gang zu
bekommen vielen dank für ihre frage ganz
konkret der versorgung
sicherheitsbericht ist ein ganz wichtige
voraussetzung für das
zertifizierungsverfahren
den das wirtschaftsministerium zu
erstellen und natürlich darüber habe ich
mich mit bundesminister habe ich schon
sehr lange unterhalten ist eine
situation wie die die jetzt eingetreten
eine in der man diese ganze lage neu
bewerten muss deshalb ist die
existierende dritte existierende bericht
wird jetzt zurückgezogen
und wird neu im wirtschaftsministerium
war in der zuständigen abteilung
bearbeitet werden und da müssen all die
fragen die uns gemeinsam bewegen
natürlich mit einfließen neben vielen
anderen die auch wichtig sind und auch
von großer bedeutung sind insofern ist
das jetzt etwas was das verfahren neu
beeinflusst und das geht jetzt an neuen
gang dass es notwendigerweise so weil
das wirtschaftsministerium jetzt diesen
bericht noch mal neu bearbeiten muss in
der nächsten zeit das wird sich sicher
hinziehen wenn ich das mal vorher sagen
darf und die zweite bemerkung ist in
bezug auf das normandie format das ist
unverändert wichtig wir haben das als
eine plattform und präsident mag und ich
haben sehr sorgfältig besprochen dass
wir die plattform auch weiter nutzen
wollen das haben wir auch mit dem
ukrainischen präsidenten zusammen
abgestimmt und wir arbeiten jetzt daran
einen weg zu suchen wie wir in der
schwierigen situation
darauf bauen können dass es das gibt als
gesprächsformat aber das will ich
ausdrücklich sagen die lage bleibt ja
ernst das ist ja so dass die truppen
immer noch da sind und dass sie alle
ausreichend sind um eine militärische
invasion der gesamten ukraine
durchzuführen und niemand von uns kann
gegenwärtig vorhersagen wie das
weitergeht deshalb ist es so wichtig
dass wir auf das was jetzt passiert ist
sofort reagieren dass es schnell
geschieht und dass die europäische union
und auch die usa und auch viele andere
da gleichgerichtet handeln und das ist
vorbereitet
das ist eine unveränderte situation
und das was wir machen ist die
ökonomische wirtschaftliche resilienz
der ukraine zu stärken indem wir
unverändert der größte finanzielle
stabilisator der ukraine sind und das
werden wir auch bleiben und dazu gehört
selbstverständlich auch dass wir jetzt
sehr eng diesen moment vorbereitet haben
und auch weitere entwicklungen die noch
platz greift die noch stattfinden können
und deshalb wird auch europa und werden
die usa schnell handeln können das
dauert jetzt nicht so lange weil wir
nicht erst anfangen sondern weil die
letzten wochen und monate damit
zugebracht haben so einen moment
vorzubereiten und genauso wie die
bundesregierung das getan hat wie sie
sehen
herr bundeskanzler egal was russland in
der ukraine vorhat und not stream hin
oder her deutschland ist und bleibt dank
bestehende pipelines ein großkunde von
erdgas aus russland
mich würde interessieren was tun sie da
um diese abhängigkeit zu bereichern
haben sie da was kurzfristig vor um
diese situation und diese abhängigkeit
von russischem erdgas zu ändern
ist party
[Musik]
es ist sehr gut dass sie diese frage
stellen wenn sie die energieversorgung
situation deutschlands betrachtet werden
sie feststellen dass etwa ein viertel
unserer energieversorgung auf gast
beruht und ein teil davon etwa die
hälfte aus russischen importen stammt
die anderen portisch dann muss norwegen
aus den niederlanden vor allem und an
vielen weiteren teilen
wir haben schon lange begonnen unsere
abhängigkeit von gas reduzieren zu
wollen indem wir entschieden haben
innerhalb von knapp 25 jahren co2
neutral zu wirtschaften deutschland wird
seine energieproduktion auf strom
basierte umstellen indem wir die
erzeugungskapazitäten für strom aus
offshore windkraft aus windkraft an land
aus solarenergie
massiv ausweiten von jetzt 600
terawattstunden auf der 800 bis zum ende
dieses jahrzehnts und dann
wahrscheinlich noch mal die doppelte
menge bis 2045 damit wir stahl zement
chemie produzieren können ohne den
einsatz fossiler ressourcen und das was
wir als gast dann einsetzen wird ein
anderes seinen anführungsstrichen
gesprochen dass wir dann wasserstoff
sein dass wir einen einsetzen werden und
den werden wir auch importieren müssen
aber zu einem erheblichen teil auch
selber erzeugen können und das ist die
aufgabe die wir uns als großes
industrielles modernisierungsprojekt
vorgenommen haben ansonsten analysieren
wir unsere situation immer sehr genau
und sorgen auch dafür dass die
importkapazitäten und import
möglichkeiten die wir künftig haben
werden um gas nach deutschland zu
bringen sich weiter diversifizieren dass
seine aufgabe die wir haben wie viele
andere auch wie sie wissen gibt es
länder in europa die wir einen viel
höheren anteil an gas für ihre
energieversorgung haben und auch einen
höheren anteil als die versorgung aus
russland betrifft insofern ist das eine
große gemeinsame europäische aufgabe die
wir auch gemeinsam schultern kann
herr bundeskanzler ich hätte ganz gerne
noch mal nachgefragt zu der europäischen
abstimmung sehen wir jetzt beide auch
der ministerpräsident die einigkeit der
europäer betont aber er ist die wirklich
gegeben sind sie ganz sicher dass alle
eu-staaten
dieses sanktionspaket mittragen oder
würden die nike minded notfalls auch
ohne einzelne länder sanktionen
verhängen und es gibt kritik daran dass
dieser abgestufter ansatz möglicherweise
keine abschreckung für putin bedeutet
weil er so ein strategisches ziel jetzt
ja schon erreicht hat er hat die ukraine
mit dieser anerkennung dauerhaft die
stabilisiert also warum nicht gleich ein
großes sanktionspaket und das ist
eigentlich das ziel also muss putin die
anerkennung zurücknehmen was möchten sie
genau erreichen danke schön dann wir
werden die
anerkennung nicht akzeptieren können und
auch nicht hinnehmen können deshalb ist
es so wichtig dass jetzt sofort um zügig
reagiert wird und da will ich den
optimismus den auch mein kollege hier
ausgedrückt hat dass wir zu einer
gemeinsamen entscheidung in der im
kommen doch noch mal unterstreichen dass
es lange diskutiert und vorbereitet
natürlich gibt es dann in den
zuständigen gremien immer noch mal
diskussion aber mein eindruck ist dass
genau das jetzt stattfinden wird ein
sehr
konzentriertes sehr starkes paket das
sich auf diese entwicklung bezieht und
die ohnehin existierende vorbereitung
für das was passieren kann wenn es zu
weiteren noch schlimmeren entwicklung
kommt die ist ja auch weit
fortgeschritten insofern statt vieler
worte ich bin eigentlich zuversichtlich
dass es gelingt die viele arbeit auch in
einem beschluss umzusetzen und halte es
auch für richtig sofort zu gehen eine
maßnahme ist jetzt auch das hier bezieht
die robustes die massiv ist und die
ähnlich ist zwischen der eu und den
vereinigten staaten von amerika und eine
maßnahme die wir maßnahmen die wir
vorbereitet für den fall dass noch mehr
passiert was wir aber unbedingt
verhindern wollen denn das ist ja das
ziel der ganzen dinge dass es nicht dazu
kommt